juan jose flores était sur place le soir
du 28 janvier lorsqu'un agent du spvm a
été désarmé et blessés dans le quartier
parc extension
c'est en quittant sa résidence pour se
rendre au travail qu'il a vu
l'altercation au coin de l'avenue
bloomfield et du boulevard crémazie la
bousculade éclatait ici exactement où je
suis maintenant puis et devenait du tout
j'ai regardé que les policières est
tombé par terre ici sur le lieu de la
taxe ce soir là monsieur flores est
certain d'avoir vu deux hommes en plus
de l'agent le premier vraisemblablement
mam a dit farah camara était assis dans
une voiture grise les mesures est restée
vive dans l'auto n'est pas sortie des
salles je peux assurer le deuxième
individu sur place le suspect impliqué
dans la sphère se serait dirigé vers
monsieur florès à pied mais me regarde
et je le regardais aussi et ensuite de a
pris la roue est là bas il est parti
mais encore aujourd'hui juan angel
flores n'arrive pas à identifier
clairement mam a dit farah camara comme
étant l'automobiliste au volant de la
voiture grise et je ne peux pas assurer
à vous la solution c'est quétaine
après american qui était dans l'auto
mais aucune idée si je tue pas 100% sûr
si c'était lui cette version des faits
juan jose flores la livrée à la police
le soir du 28 janvier
la même chose que j'ai
déjà vu la même chose que dit la police
malgré le témoignage de monsieur florès
mam a dit farah camara a quand même été
arrêté et détenu six jours le récit du
témoin at il été écarté par la police
les témoins qui donne une version des
faits sont tous pris en considération
mais dans une urgence comme la situation
on a vécu
souvent on va regarder l'ensemble des
faits recueillis la situation mais aussi
la version d'autres témoins dont la
victime qui le politique selon marcel
savard la déposition de juan angel
flores a certainement joué un rôle de
premier plan dont le retrait des
accusations contre monsieur camara un
revirement de situation extraordinaire
ici et met le mieux
radio canada montréal